well as you can imagine the Ukrainian
authorities are very angry about this
their language is completely consistent
with the kind of language that we've
heard from their International
predominantly Western allies and the UN
they are describing this referendum as a
complete sham lacking any kind of legal
basis on the international in an
international context whatsoever we've
had reaction already from the Ukrainian
foreign minister dimitro kaleba he's
calling for even tougher sanctions from
the EU in his words he says that the
softer the reaction is from the European
Union the greater that will give Russia
even more motivation to potentially try
at least to Annex even more territory
let's keep in mind that this uh what is
being seen is a potential attempt to
Annex around 15 of Ukraine by Russia an
area roughly the size of of Portugal has
huge implications and we were speaking
yesterday to one of the presidential
advisors of Mr Michaela podaliak he drew
attention to the farcical nature in his
words of these referendum for the mere
fact that Russia does not control fully
at least any of these four regions for
example it's held a referendum in the
region of zaparizio it doesn't even
control the main city the regional
capital zapariza city so there are huge
questions here as to what what will come
from this there is a concern of an
increased escalation in fighting let's
have a listen to what more Michaela
podaleak told us yesterday
foreign there is no legality to this
referendum because it's pure propaganda
it'll have no consequences in
international law this is Ukraine's
territory and it will remain Ukraine
territory secondly you cannot conduct a
referendum legally when there is a war
on this occupied territory and when
people go door to door with weapons
forcing people to vote this vote doesn't
change anything when we understand that
Russia is on the path of escalation and
we will liberate all our territory
President zielinski says that Russian
action and holding this vote will
completely block any peace negotiation
process
so we've already heard from the United
States it's understood that they are
planning an additional series of
sanctions and and more arms to be sent
it's understood
um and arms uh an arms cache worth
around 1.1 billion Bearer in mind that
America has already sent or committed to
around nine billion dollars worth of
weapons already the UK as well has
slapped additional sanctions on um what
they describe as Russians having been
involved in organizing and implementing
this what they say is an illegal
referendum
um hodaliak also said interestingly that
ukrainians found to have taken part in
this referendum certainly organizing it
faced treason charges and up to five
years in jail he also said that in no
way was Ukraine intimidated by Russia's
nuclear threats we know that President
Putin made a veiled Thread about
potentially using nuclear weapons he
said that this makes absolutely no
difference to Ukraine's policy and
strategy they would continue to push
forward to deoccupying his words all of
Russian occupied territory the territory
that Russia controls and on that front
some interesting lines coming out
overnight about fighting in the East
most particularly around a very
strategic town called liman that is uh
just north of the town of the sloviansk
of huge strategic importance because it
is a massive rail Hub very heavy
fighting we understand going on around
Lee man there are also reports that uh
certainly unverifiable that Russian
forces may have lost control to
Ukrainian military on their Northern
flank of that City bear in mind that
over the last couple of days the
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
has says their number one priority now
the Ukrainian Army is to defend and then
push back
Russian forces out of Donetsk region we
understand and that Ukrainian forces
control only around 40 percent of
danette's kanzilinski's words this is
our number one priority because it seems
as it as if it is Russia's number one
priority too so as we've been reporting
this referendum seems to only really be
stimulating potentially more fighting in
the coming days and weeks Charles
Stratford uh with that update from Kiev
thank you